[Applause]
you good hello January 1968 the North
Vietnamese Army's launched a surprise
attack against the American forces in
the country it was Tet which is the
Lunar New Year and there was a tradition
in Vietnam that lasted decades that
there was never any fighting on Tet but
this year in 1968 the North Vietnamese
generals decided that they would break
with tradition with the hope that they
would overwhelm American forces and
bring about a swift end to the war
this was the Tet Offensive they threw
85,000 troops at over 125 targets across
the country catching the Americans
completely by surprise many of the
commanders weren't even at their posts
they were in whatever local town or
village celebrating Tet here's the
amazing thing the United States military
repelled every single attack every
single one most of the major fighting
had ceased after about a week after
which the United States had lost fewer
than a thousand troops so a few hundred
troops North Vietnam had lost
thirty-five thousand of the eighty-five
thousand troops 'we went on for about a
month there about a hundred Marines were
lost and 1,500 North Vietnamese were
lost over the course of ten years in
Vietnam America lost 58,000 men North
Vietnam lost over three million people
that's an equivalent to 27 million
Americans in 1968 and if you look at the
Vietnam War America won nearly every
single major battle it fought so it
raises a very interesting question how
do you win most the battles how do you
decimate your enemy
and lose the war clearly we don't fully
understand this concept of winning and
losing it's not simply the score that we
keep there's something more to it
there's a wonderful man by the name of
James Carr C is a theologian he used to
teach at NYU who wrote this wonderful
little book called finite and infinite
games and in it he defines these two
types of games finite games and infinite
games if you have at least one
competitor you have a game and there are
two types of games find a games and
infinite games finite games are defined
as known players fixed rules and an
agreed upon objective football we all
agree to the rules of the game and we
all agree that whoever has more goals at
the end of the game is the winner we all
go home an infinite game is defined by
known and unknown players the rules are
changeable and the objective is to
perpetuate the game to keep the game in
play when you pit a finite player versus
a finite player the system is stable
football is stable when you pit an
infinite player versus an infinite
player the system is also stable the
Cold War was stable because we could not
have a winner or a loser we just both
kept playing to make sure that the game
stayed in play that's what cabe kept it
stable there's no such thing as winning
or losing an infinite game what happens
is when the player or one of the players
runs out of the will or resources to
continue to play they drop out of the
game but the game continues with you or
without you problems arise however when
you pit a finite player versus an
infinite player because finite players
are playing to win and infinite players
are playing to keep playing and they'll
make very different strategic choices as
a result and this is what happened to
America in Vietnam America was fighting
to win and the North Vietnamese were
fighting for their lives and they would
fight to the very last men if necessary
and when a finite player finds
themselves against an infinite player
they will always find themselves in
quagmire racing through the will and
resources to stay in the game so this
gets me thinking we are surrounded every
day of our lives by infinite games we
are all unwitting
players in these infinite games there's
no such thing as being number one in
marriage there's no such thing as
winning in your friendships there's no
such thing as winning global politics
and there's definitely no such thing as
winning business but if we listen to the
language of too many leaders they don't
know the game they're in they talk about
being number one being the best beating
your competition based on what it
agreed-upon metrics based on what
agreed-upon timeframes meaning the vast
majority of our businesses are on even
of our of our political leaders are
playing by finite rules in an infinite
game which means we're racing through
the will and resources to stay in the
game and business we call it bankruptcy
or a merger and acquisition which means
we need to completely readjust how we
think about leadership to actually play
for the game were in and the reason is
important because when we play with a
finite mindset in the infinite game
there's a few very predictable things
that happen there's a decline of trust
there's a decline of cooperation and
there's a decline of innovation I had a
real life experience that showed me what
the difference between the two games was
I spoke at an education summit for
Microsoft I also spoke at an education
summit for Apple at the Microsoft summit
I would say that 70 to 80 percent of the
executives spent about 70 to 80 percent
of their presentations talking about how
to beat Apple at the Apple Summit a
hundred percent of the executives spent
a hundred percent of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn one was
obsessed with where they were going the
other one was obsessed with beating
their competition guess which one was in
quagmire guess which one was wait racing
through the will and resources to stay
in the game at the end of my talk at
Microsoft they gave me a gift they gave
me the new Zune when it was a thing this
was Microsoft's answer to the iPod this
little piece of technology was
absolutely fantastic the user interface
was simple it was easy to understand it
was elegant it worked flawlessly it was
a brilliant little piece of technology
I'm sharing a taxi with a senior
executive from Apple after the Apple
talk and I couldn't help myself I just
had to stir the pot so I turned him and
I say you know Microsoft gave me their
new Zune it is so much better than your
iPod touch
and he looks at me and he says I have no
doubt and the conversation was over
because an infinite player understands
that sometimes you have the better
product and sometimes they have the
better product and there's no such thing
as winning or being the best there's
only ahead and behind and the only true
competitor in an infinite game is
yourself the goal is to make a better
product this year than you had last year
to ensure that your culture is stronger
this year than it was last year that
your leaders are growing at a stronger
pace this year than they were last year
that everything about your organization
your systems everything is improving
improving and improving it's constant
improvement there is no end to this game
it's a game of constant improvement
which means if we have to completely
reconfigure how we think about
leadership for the infinite game it begs
the question well how're we supposed to
lead in the infinite game there are five
things that have to happen to really
become a leader for the infinite game
one you have to have a Just Cause two
you have to have trusting teams three
you have to have a worthy adversary for
you have to have existential flexibility
and five you have to have the courage to
lead just cause it just cause there's a
purpose or cause that is so just you
would willingly sacrifice to be a part
of it it doesn't have to be sacrifice
your life but you would turn down a
higher paying job because you'd rather
stay here and be a part of what you're
doing now it means that you willingly
work late hours or go on business trips
or maybe not see your family as much you
don't like it but it's worth it it feels
worth it that's what a Just Cause is
there are many great just causes out
there Apple was founded on the premise
that individuals should be able to stand
up to Big Brother
that's why they're so appealing to
creatives and young people people who
like the idea of standing up to Big
Brother the United States wrote in the
Declaration of Independence all men are
created equal endowed with these
unalienable rights amongst which include
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness it is an ideal just causes or
a description of the future States so
ideal that for all practical purposes we
will never actually achieve that vision
but we will die trying
that is the point this is what gives our
lives and our work meaning that it's not
about simply achieving some sort of
metric hitting some sort of goal that
has no purpose but rather that every
goal we hit is a marker that we're
making progress towards something even
bigger
it's about momentum not about absolutes
yes metrics are very very important they
help us count speed and distance and
every milestone we pass makes us feel
like we're getting closer and closer
which we energizes that we can do this
we can do this you have to have adjust
cause sometimes we use the word vision I
don't like the word vision because
there's no standard definition of it I
talk to companies all the time I say
what's your company's vision to be the
biggest in our industry by 2024 what's
your vision they give me a dollar sign
an amount that they want to hit it's
they it's nothing to do with the vision
the reason we call it vision is because
you have to be able to see it imagine a
world that is different to the one we
have now that you believe that if
everything that you did in your
organization went perfectly you would
contribute to the building of that world
I have a vision I imagine a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired feel
safe at work and return home fulfilled
at the end of the day I have completely
devoted everything I do to help advance
this vision of the world I know I won't
ever get there but I'll die trying
that is the point every organization
that says we choose trust every
organization that says we choose people
before profit every organization that
says there's got to be a better way in
which we're doing this every
organization that wants to
tech tits people means we're making
progress towards this world that I
imagine again it what gives our lives
and our work meaning we will willingly
devote our lives to these just causes
too many people go looking for a cause
you know depending on what job they're
in this is I have friends you know they
have a job and I'm like do you feel like
you're part of something bigger than
yourself they go absolutely then they
quit or they get fired and then they say
no this this this new job this is the
thing I wanted to do and they quit or
they get fired and they got a new job
like this this is the one every job you
have regardless of where you quit or get
fired it doesn't matter every job you
have to be contributing to the same
vision and the thing about vision that's
so interesting is we don't have to put
pressure on ourselves to be visionary
there's a very small handful of people
in our population who are visionary
you're Steve Jobs is you're Richard
Branson's true visionaries we don't have
to have a vision we have to find a
vision if there was someone else's
vision that that gives us goosebumps if
there's someone else's vision that we
say that's the world I want to live and
I have a dream said Martin Luther King
that one day little black children will
hold hands on the playground with other
white children if you want to live in
that world choose his and devote your
live and devote your career to helping
build that vision in some way shape or
form even if it's only small steps
that's what makes us feel a part of
something bigger than ourselves find
division is the important part it's so
important when we talk to organizations
to ask them what do you believe what is
the vision what is the Just Cause number
two trusting teams I went on a business
trip to Las Vegas and they put me up at
the Four Seasons out there beautiful
hotel the reason it's a beautiful hotel
is not because of the beds
any hotel can buy a fancy bed it's
because of the people who work there
that when you walk through the hallways
and somebody says hello you get the
distinct feeling that they wanted to say
hello
they were told to say hello we can tell
the difference we're highly attuned
social animals we can tell the
difference in this kind of behave you
can always tell when somebody's working
on Commission right you can tell they
happen to have a coffee a coffee bar in
the in the lobby and so one afternoon I
went to buy myself a cup of coffee and
the barista working the day is a kid
named Noah Noah was funny and charming
and engaging and I stood there for far
too long
joking around with Noah just to buy a
cup of coffee so as is my nature
I asked Noah do you like your job
without skipping a beat Noah said I love
my job
now to someone in my line of work that's
significant because like is rational I
like the people I work with I like the
challenge I get paid well I like my job
love is emotional it's a it's a
higher-order thing do you love your wife
I like her a lot it's different
Noah said I love my job so immediately I
followed up tell me specifically I asked
what the four seasons is doing that you
would say to me you love your job
without skipping a beat Noah said that
throughout the day managers will walk
past me and ask me how I'm doing
ask me if there's anything that that I
need to do my job better not just my
manager any manager and then he said I
also work at Caesar's Palace and they're
the managers walk past us and catch us
if we're doing anything wrong there they
want to make sure we're doing everything
right they want to make the numbers I
like to keep my head below the radar and
just get through the day and collect my
paycheck he said only at the four
seasons do I feel I can be myself
that's a trusting team that's what a
circle of safety is when we come to work
and we feel we can be ourselves we feel
that we can make mistakes we feel like
our bosses are there to see us succeed I
get this question all the time Simon how
do I get the most out of my people like
they're a towel that you wring it's a
flawed question the question is how do I
help create an environment in which my
people can work at their natural best
then the answers will be entirely
different that's called good leadership
and the leaders responsibility is to
create an environment in which people
can work to their natural best in which
the people can trust each other develop
these trusting teams trusting teams is
something very specific
trusting teams means that someone can
come to work and raise their hand and
say I made a mistake I don't feel like I
have adequate training to do the job
you've asked me to do I'm scared I'm
having problems at home and it's
affecting my work I need help without
any fear of humiliation or retribution
if anything they say these things with
absolute confidence that people will
rush in to help them if we do not have
trusting teams what we do have is a
group of people who show up to work
every single day lying hiding
faking there would never admit mistakes
for fear that had put them on some short
list for redundancies the next time they
come up or get in trouble they're never
gonna tell you that you've promoted them
and they don't know how to do their job
for fear that that they haven't earned
it or they're not good enough whether
they're gonna lose your trust they're
never going to admit that they're having
trouble at home and it's affecting their
work for fear that if they were to take
a day off it would affect them and
there's certainly you're never gonna say
they need help well guess what happens
to an organization with the majority of
people aren't admitting mistakes and
aren't saying they need help eventually
things start to break they start to
compound we saw it happen remember the
news a couple years ago United Airlines
dragged a passenger a paying passenger
off their aircraft with a broken nose a
concussion and broken two broken teeth I
feel sorry for every member of that crew
because 100% of them knew that that was
the wrong thing to do and did not
intervene because they feared getting in
trouble more than they feared doing the
right thing they stood back and watched
this was not an anomaly this did not
happen overnight this was not a one-time
occurrence
I flew United Airlines the years before
and some I saw something play out in
front of me that was a red flag I was
waiting to board the aircraft and I an
Essene played out in front of me where
one of the passengers attempted to board
the plane before their group number was
called high crimes and misdemeanors
and the gate agent yelled at him step
aside sir I haven't called your group
yet please step aside and wait till I
call your group as how she talked to a
paying customer I spoke up I said why do
you have to talk to us that way
why can't you talk to us like we're
human beings and she looked me in the
eye and said sir if I don't follow the
rules I could get in trouble or lose my
job which she revealed to me is that she
does not feel safe in our own
organization her leaders do not trust
her to do the dot job for which she's
been trained to do and guess who suffers
customer and company the reason we fly
like flying virgin or Southwest Airlines
any of these other airlines is not
because they have some magical formula
to hire the best people it's because the
people who work there feel safe they
feel like they have agency they feel
like they can make decisions in their
own jobs and they feel like their
leaders trust them to do the job for
which they've been trained to do and
guess who benefits customer and company
that's what creating a circle of safety
is that's what a trusting team is that
people feel like they have control and
agency of it too over their own jobs I I
spoke at a large energy company I did a
workshop with some senior executives a
large energy company in the United
States and it was an unbelievably hot
room they had us in so I said I asked
something seemingly very obvious but you
think we could turn up the air
conditioning and we came back after
luncheon was the afternoon many hours
since my request and it was still
unbelievably hot and I said were we able
to turn up the air conditioning they
said yes we told the facilities people
here they had to send the request to
headquarters in Houston we're waiting
for Houston to get back to us before
they can turn down the air conditioning
that's the air conditioning imagine how
the rest of that organization works
that everyone there is afraid to make a
decision no one has any agency or
control and there's one thing we know
about human beings that our sense of
enjoyment from our work does not come
from work-life balance and how much yoga
we do our sense of enjoyment at work and
that the sense of stress we have is all
about our sense of control that when we
feel like we have control over our work
we actually enjoy it more and control is
taken away from us
well--we're fear making any kind of
decision whatsoever we actually that's
what increases stress dramatically
amongst human beings if you want to play
in the infinite game you have to have
trusting teams people are willing to
help each other when things go wrong
people are willing to admit mistakes but
if we can't keep the organization self
improving it will break number three
worthy rival there's another guy who
does what I do he writes books he does
the speaking thing and he's
exceptionally good at what he does he's
incredibly well-respected I personally
really admire his work and I hate him
I'm not being funny I actually hate him
he's never done anything mean to me he's
always been very polite and charming
whenever I see him it's irrational I
hate him what do you want to tell you
and I will regularly go on the internet
and check my book rankings and then
immediately check his I don't check
anyone elses just his and if I'm a head
I'm smug and if he's a head I fume and
when people bring up his name I sort of
like yeah he's great so we were invited
to speak at the same event once I don't
mean like him in the morning me in the
afternoon mean afternoon I mean like on
the stage we were gonna get interviewed
together and the interviewer thought it
would be fun if we introduced each other
so I went first I turned to him on the
stage and I said you make me incredibly
insecure I said all of your strengths
are all of my weaknesses and whatever
your name comes up it makes me
uncomfortable he looked at me he said
funny I think the same about you
the reason I hated him had nothing to do
with him it's because he reminded me he
revealed to me his very existence
revealed to me my weaknesses and it was
much easier to take that energy and put
it against someone than it was to admit
to myself that I've got I've got some
work to do it was an amazingly cathartic
experience that day I have never since
checked his rankings and I actually love
him now and I've stayed at his house and
we talk to each other all the time he's
become a dear friend I'm not gonna tell
you
there's a whole moral to the story that
has nothing to do with who it is
it's fiction maybe it's a whole fiction
it's actually not so I said the only
true competitor in an infinite game is
yourself but what you have to have as a
worthy rival someone who is better than
you in your own industry perhaps or in
another industry who's better at
something that you do and instead of
hating them and trying to beat them and
trying to outdo them we learn from them
we admire them we respect them because
they by revealing to us our weaknesses
it gives us tools to go back and then
see where we need to improve and we wish
them the best of luck it's not about
them it's about us because the goal is
not to beat them the goal is to simply
improve and stay in the game as long as
possible and if they drop out before us
so be it the game will continue with
them or without them a worthy rival
Apple in the early days had IBM big blue
IBM represented the Navy and Apple were
the Pirates and then IBM dropped out of
game then it was Microsoft hi I'm a Mac
I'm a PC they represented the Navy and
Apple rep that represented the the
Pirates and then they dropped out of the
game and now it's Google and Facebook
that Apple is pitting themselves against
in terms of privacy and other things
like that a worthy rival reveals to us
our weaknesses so that may we may go
back in and prove if we're obsessed with
beating our competition it's like
running in a race and tripping near the
competitor you will win the race but
you're still a slow runner and the
problem is there's gonna be another race
and another race and another race and
another race and it never ends sure you
win a couple but you're still a slow
runner the point is to get better
yourself have a worthy rival know who
they are they can be companies they can
even be individuals at work I completely
am against the idea of creating internal
competition I heard this from companies
all the time
we like to drive performance by pinning
our people against each other
well that means they're gonna undermine
each other I want my people to share
information not hoard it I want my
people to help other divisions not
complain about them but rivalry is good
you can absolutely have rivals in your
own company people who you
are better your job than you people who
are better leaders than you that you
look at them say I want to be like that
girl I don't be like that guy they're so
good
they make me insecure they're so good
those are the people to admire have
rivals absolutely again it's another
tool for constant improvement which is
what we need in the infinite game number
four is the capacity for existential
flexibility so there's something really
funny when you think about what is
existential if you compare finite games
and infinite games in in a finite game
it's the game that ends so the football
game ends but the players continue to
exist until there's another game they
just wait to play another game right the
game ends in the infinite game it's the
players that disappear the game is
constant but the players cease to exist
companies go bankrupt the Roman Empire
doesn't exist anymore the players
disappear so this concept of existential
flexibility is literally existential can
you stay in the game because you're the
one that's gonna disappear the capacity
for existential flexibility is quite
simply a dramatic shift in strategy
because you find a better way to advance
your cause so in the early days of Apple
Apple had already come up come had come
off the success of the Apple one in the
Apple two it's the late 70s early 80s
and their next big computer was whatever
they were developing and coincidentally
jobs and a few of his senior executives
went to visit Xerox PARC which was the
Innovation Center for Xerox and Xerox
showed them a new technology that they
had invented called the graphic user
interface where you could you didn't
have to learn a computer language to use
a computer which is how it used to be
but now you could use this thing called
a mouse and you could move a cursor on a
desktop and click on folders and
move them around and things to use the
computer and job so this technology and
thought this was amazing if he's trying
to empower individuals to stand up to
Big Brother
this means that way more people would
have access to the technology than the
people who learn a computer language and
as they left Xerox PARC he said to his
guys we have to invest in this graphic
user interface thing and one of the
executives the voice of reason said
Steve we can't we've already invested
millions of dollars and countless
man-hours in a completely distant
different strategic direction if we
abandon that we'll blow up her own
company to which jobs actually said
better we should blowed up than someone
else that decision became the Macintosh
a technology so profound that the entire
software of Windows is designed to look
like a Macintosh the reason we all have
computers at home and at work is because
of that decision to the outside world it
looks like you're crazy to do that that
you would risk the loss of money or the
potential failure why would you abandon
something that's working for something
that might not work but to the person
who makes the decision because they are
driven by just cause it is so easy them
for them to see that staying on the path
they're on is the path that will lead to
death that this decision is the obvious
choice and the money means nothing
because it means survival and can
ability to continue to thrive
existential flexibility so George
Eastman was also a visionary he was a
young guy working in a bank in Rochester
New York and he decided he wanted to be
an entrepreneur he was 22 years 12 21
years old son like that and so everybody
was land prospecting back in those days
with like the dot-com and so he want to
become a land prospector and he was
already too he was going to go on a trip
to prospect land and a colleague of his
from the banks that you should take a
camera to take pictures of the land that
you want to prospect for reference the
problem was in those days
the main way you could take a picture
was you had to hire photographers you
couldn't take pictures of your own
holiday you can take pictures of your
own family only professional
photographers could do that so Eastman
ended up not going on the trip but he
actually stick tup the hobby of
photography and the problems are so
complicated
he'd have take all of these chemicals in
these camera the size of a microwave
oven and tents to load the film and the
guy was like well I kind of be a little
simpler this is ridiculous I just want
to take pictures for fun it's not my
business and so he figures out a way to
coat the plates the the the film plate
so we didn't have to do would deal with
all the toxic chemicals out in the field
turns out other photographers wanted his
plates and they started buying them so
he proves upon the technology and
invents something called film where now
you could take a hundred pictures on a
flexible piece of film built into the
camera he flies to England to present
his technology at what's their
equivalent of a technology show was a
big photography show here where they
people come from miles around to see
whatever his latest and greatest latest
and greatest like what's the big thing
in Vegas oh he just see yes thank you it
was like CES and it was a huge hit
everybody thought this film thing was
absolutely unbelievable it was
incredible and nobody will bought one it
was a complete commercial disaster
because the quality of the photographs
wasn't good enough they were too grainy
and for professionals they needed high
quality film now for any of us for any
of us who are entrepreneurs who came up
with the technology the obvious choice
would be to go back improve the
technology the demand is like begging
for your product we just have to in fix
the technology and we're good to go
that's not what George Eastman did
because he was obsessed with
democratizing photography and even if he
got it right how many professional
photographers are there he wanted to
make it easier for the rest of us just
like he made it easy for himself so he
made an existencial flex
he completely abandoned the professional
market and he said you know there's an
entire market that doesn't care about
the quality of the photograph the
general population and they marketed the
camera and the flexible film to the
general population it is because of
George Eastman that we take our own
pictures of our own families and our own
holidays George Eastman went on to build
Kodak a word he made up by the way cuz
he thought K was a strong sounding
letter and he went on to be one of the
richest men in the world up there with
the Carnegie's and the Rockefellers
years later a company that continued to
be obsessed with the democratizing of
technology that had continued to make it
easier and easier and easier for us to
take pictures in 1975 Kodak invented the
digital camera and when the young man
who invented it showed it to the
executives first they complained about
the quality of the picture then they
said nobody wants to look at pictures on
a screen and then they decided to
suppress the technology for fear that it
would cannibalize film sales and they
built an entire company based and they
made the paper they made the chemicals
they made the machines they made the
film all based on this one thing and
they couldn't imagine having to
reconfigure their company for something
different they gave themselves ten years
they knew somebody else would figure out
the digital thing and they gave
themselves ten years and over the course
of those ten years you know what they
did nothing and yes new technology
started to emerge and code action at
Kodak actually made billions of dollars
licensing their patents for the digital
camera and then when those patents ran
out three years later they went bankrupt
because they didn't have the capacity
for existential flexibility if you're
not willing to blow up your company the
market will blow it up for you that's
exactly what happened there was a
limited runway they had the cause they
chose to abandon the cause in order to
do something finite in order to do
something to protect the certainty of
the future versus doing something that
they know is the right thing to do for
the
long-term that's the capacity of
existential flexibility which leads to
the final point the courage to lead I
always joke that it's a little
embarrassing that I have to have courage
on the list but the reason it's there is
because everything that I have told you
today is unbelievably difficult all of
the pressures in our lives whether it's
from the markets or from our families or
from the incentive structures in our
companies are trying to force us to
consider the finite they're trying to
force us to consider the short term over
the long term consider profit before
people and by the way when I talk about
putting people before profits I don't
mean like 1% profit 99% people like it
can be like 5149 it means there's a bias
it means that when there's a decision
that we know that one of them is going
to be sacrificed we lean towards people
doesn't mean we're anti profit remember
to stay in the game you need resources
and the will to stay in the game
profitability is important but you have
a bias for people that's hard that's
hard it's much easier to have
redundancies rather than figure out a
way to protect them if you look at all
the companies we admire all of the ones
that I would consider infinite leaders
either they've never had the done
dancies or they only use them very very
sparingly in extreme times and they're
very very embarrassed that they did and
it was a complete shock to their system
that they're still reeling from and they
admitted that takes courage do you know
how much courage it takes to make an
existential flex with cause in mind why
are you making this change because I
have a vision of a future that's
completely unrealizable and that's why
I'm gonna change the direction of my
company
walt disney did it the guy in basically
invented animation like we have it today
he was the first one to put sound to an
animation he was the first one to make a
feature-length animated film Snow White
where you could be physically
transported but the problem was once you
were done with the film it was over he
wanted to physically keep people in the
movie in in in the fantasy and after all
that success no one would let him make
the parks and so he sold all of his
interests in Walt Disney Animation and
he quit to start an entirely new company
and he had to self fund it because he
says he couldn't put up his dreams as
collateral with the bank they're not
interested in his dream as collateral
and that became Disneyland which to this
day makes I think more money than any
other division in Disney and continues
to grow and grow and grow it is infinite
Disney Land contends to improve that was
truly what his vision was that takes
courage to put it all on the line it
takes courage to say I don't know what
I'm doing and the leader has to set the
example that's scary because we think we
have to have all the answers we have to
be tough all the time to MIT admit fail
ability it's hard to admit that there
are other people out there that are
better than us we've all been in new
business pitches and somebody says what
about your competition and we come up
with some nonsense about how we're
actually better than them
when deep down and we saw it inside we
know there's so much better than us
I used I remember this back in the early
days when I had a marketing consultancy
before all that why stuff and all this
the career I'm on now
and I remember used to go into new
business pitches and I was I remember
being so brutally honest you know I
would say I'm really good at this I'm ok
at this you should not hire me for this
and they kept wanted me to hire me for
everything just because I was honest
because every other pitch that they had
the day before they were up that other
company was brilliant at everything then
even though they knew that I sucked at
these things they just knew I'd be
honest when things broke
there's something to be said for honesty
we trust on his people
it's anthropological its biological
there's no escaping it it goes back to
too early early early mankind when
somebody says there's danger it has to
actually be there when somebody says
there's no danger you're fine we have to
actually believe them that's why we take
recommendations from close friends and
not strangers like if some stranger
walks up to you on the street says you
should see this movie but if your friend
says you should see this movie you like
rush out and buy a ticket you don't even
read the reviews trust there's something
to be said for honesty it's hard being
honest all the time it's really hard
do I look fat in these jeans
I like the other genes better nobody
said honesty has to be mean the courage
to lead fundamentally means you're
willing to be open-minded to consider
that maybe just maybe the way you think
the world works may be wrong and the way
we've been building our business based
on all the social conventions and what
everybody tells us are the right things
to do maybe is wrong and just because
everyone's doing it doesn't mean it's
right
remember the vast majority of the
business philosophies and practices that
we practice today are not norms of
business they're recent
they come from the 70s and 80s the
concept of Sharyl to supremacy where we
prioritize the interest of an external
shareholder over the interests of our
employers or customers was a theory
proposed the late 1970s popularized in
the 80s and 90s by bastards like Jack
Welch who ran GE the concept of using
mass layoffs to meet an arbitrary
financial projection at the end of the
year did not exist prior to the 1980s it
was popularized by bastards like Jack
Welch and General Electric rank and yank
the idea of ranking your employees based
on performance
promoting the top 10% and firing the
bottom 10% did not exist prior to mr.
Welch and this man named Milton Friedman
an economist that gained this guy a
Nobel Prize they gave Milton Freeman
Nobel Prize he is credited with
basically offering us what is considered
the accepted definition of the
responsibility of business
he said the responsibility of business
is to maximize profits within the bounds
of the law
what happened to ethics because ethics
is a much higher standard than the law
the makers of the Titanic in the early
20th century built a ship that was four
times larger than any other ship of the
day and the regulations that govern
lifeboats were based on the size of the
ship and they didn't yet have a
lifeboats for all provision it said if
your ship is this size you need this
many lifeboats if your ship as the side
you need this many lifeboats and their
ship was four times larger than the
largest so they knew that eventually the
regulation would catch up that
eventually you'd have a lifeboats for
all provision in the law but until it
did man literally to save money that was
their reason to save money they left
empty berths on the Titanic where the
lifeboats will go when the law catches
up but until then we'll just put nothing
so they only had 25 percent of the
required lifeboats for the number of
passengers that were on board the
Titanic we all know what happened in
1912 it hit an iceberg you want to guess
how many people died you right 75
percent they broke no laws think about
the number of CEOs that get dragged out
in front of the court of public opinion
after they've done something
disgustingly unethical and what do they
all say we were then down to the law we
broke no law this is the standard for
business and so people who are
anti-capitalist now what they've
completely failed to understand is that
the capitalism we have is not actually
capitalism as Adam Smith envisioned it
we have a bastardized capitalism
capitalism for bastards if you like
and the capitalism we practice today is
not actually the purest form of
capitalism it actually undermines
capitalism where we have increasing
levels of stress we have declining
levels of Technology in declining levels
of trust declining levels of cooperation
we have unstable economies is because of
this false view of capitalism that we
have as Adam Smith envisioned it it was
about trust it was about cooperation it
was about human beings he believed that
you prioritize people over profit he
actually wrote in The Wealth of Nations
that I don't need to speak any further
about it it's obvious and then didn't
write anything else about it that's why
we have to challenge the system that's
why we need an infinite mindset that's
why we have to have the courage to stand
up to Milton Friedman and say you're
wrong I don't care about your prize well
he's the he must be right it's to stand
up to bastards like Jack Welch and
people who've immortalized him and to
say no our form of capitalism
prioritizes people trust cooperation
empathy maternal instinct longevity not
not the same as long-term or sustainable
I don't use the word long-term 20 years
of long term 30 years long term infinite
which all raises a very interesting
question what does it mean to live in
infinite life clearly our lives are
finite but life is infinite we are the
players in them an infinite game we're
born we die we come we go the game goes
on with us or without us the game
doesn't care and like the game of
business like the game of Education like
the game of global politics we do not
get to pick the game but we do get to
pick how we play that is the only choice
we have and if we choose to live our
lives the finite mindset
we're playing to win we're playing for
somebody else to lose
we're playing to advance our careers
faster than everybody else to make more
money than everybody else we're
comparing the scores constantly we're
slicing and dicing to show that we're
the best we're number one we get to make
up the numbers in the timeframes but
it's really important to us that
everybody thinks we're number one you
don't build trust that way cooperation
it's hard to come by
innovation forget about it you'll be
rich and then when you die you don't get
to take any of it with you and we won't
miss you
we'll forget your name and your business
will probably close right after you or
if it doesn't it'll go like this slowly
if it's large it can afford to stay in
business for a while but that doesn't
mean it's permanent or we can choose to
live our lives with an infinite mindset
it means we give our businesses a cause
worth coming to work for we give our
families a cause worth helping each
other out for we commit ourselves to
being the leaders we wish we had we
commit ourselves to building circles of
safety which people feel safe and we
trust each other and we're willing to
take risks to be vulnerable to set the
tone because if we take care of each
other this can outlast me we're willing
to have rivals and be honest about our
weaknesses and admit that there are
other people who are much better at what
we do than us and we should learn from
them we're willing to make that massive
shift if we find a better way to advance
our cause and we will have the courage
to say to all the people who say that
we're crazy idealistic yeah yeah we are
yeah I'll take my risk I'll take my risk
because fundamentally that's what the
infinite mindset is it's a code for the
idealists to operate in a world that is
telling us we should be a real realistic
it's a code for people who believe that
an unrealizable vision that's worth
devoting our lives to advance is better
than a short-term goal the choice to
live an infinite life means that we
leave a legacy it means that when we
pass others will pick up the torch and
continue without us I had a chance to
sit next to Richard Branson at dinner
once
and I asked him when you die
how should we judge you how should we
judge your success I asked him I said
what did you do at virgin that we will
look back and say you were successful
and he said do not judge me by anything
I did at virgin if you want to judge my
life you judge me by the quality of my
children that's an infinite mindset that
is someone who's lived their life with
the expectation that other people will
carry a torch and all of the foundations
he laid were not for profit they were
not for fame they were to keep the torch
burning the choice is ours thanks
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so let's do questions can we bring the
house lights up please house lights
house lights all the way up in the back
- yeah it's so nice to see you so we
have microphones there there ms2 up top
as well I can't see them but I know that
it there and there so go to the mics and
then other people can hear your
questions and if you have babysitter's
you can go I won't be I won't be
offended hi Simon I'm Lauren lovely to
meet you hello one of my favorite
stories that you tell is the one about
Bob Chapman
mm-hm and how bob has he believes in
heart count mm-hmm rather than head
count and how he introduced the furlough
program and when I first heard that I
was so moved because I've never worked
in any company and I've worked in you
know many and I can't think of a single
company that would have employed that
mm-hm
so is it that it's very rare that people
have the courage to leave but it really
is based on who they are as a human and
their desire or can that be something
that gets that become that builds
momentum and the people see that it's
the right thing to do because otherwise
how do you connect to see change I ask
the corporate world she's referring to a
gentleman by the name of Bob Chapman who
I wrote about quite extensively in the
book leaders eat last and as you said in
Bob's company they do not have a
headcount they have a heart count in it
in hard times it's very hard to reduce a
heart count it's a way of viewing human
beings and they view that they have the
belief that every single person in their
company is someone's son and someone's
daughter and they keep that in mind
every time they make a decision that I'm
responsible for someone's son and
someone's daughter and yes it is who
Bobby is I mean he is that is who he is
he uses humanity and idealism
he he's a kind of remarkable human being
and the question was we want more of Bob
chapman's so my friend George Flinn who
was a retired Marine general said the
first criteria to be a leader is you
have to want to be one right so if you
enlist in the United States Marine Corps
you cannot drop out you can you can't
change your mind at any stage and say
I'd like to leave please when you're at
boot camp and you hate your life you
signed a contract they will not let you
out nothing if you want to be an officer
in the United States Marine Corps of the
ten weeks of training you can drop out
for the first six weeks you can just
leave no questions asked they'll let you
out of the contract because their
attitude is we don't want leaders who
don't want to be leaders and so the
choice to be a leader is a decision that
comes first but then the education to
become a leader is a lifestyle it's like
the choice to become healthy right and
at the early days it's usually a lot of
heavy lifting and a steep learning curve
I have to change the way I eat and I
have to go to the gym I hate that and
then you get into shape and you feel
good and you look good and your doctor
is very happy with you and the worst
part is once you're in shape you have to
keep going to the gym and eating healthy
for the rest of your life it's not
something you do achieve your goal and
then stop it's a it's the choice to live
a life that way even though they might
have been a finite goal in a short term
leadership is the same it is a lifestyle
it is an it is a muscle that it requires
constant exercise and though you may
study all of the theory about leadership
and you may have been good at it at one
time if you don't keep it up the muscle
atrophy and the problem is too many
people in leadership positions would
rather be in authority than maintain the
lifestyle of leadership they think that
once they get rank it in Taoism would
certain powers and it doesn't it doesn't
the good news is is there's a movement
we're here talking about leadership
we're changing the vernacular of what
leadership means we're using terminology
like servant leadership ship more you
hear people demanding that their
companies have purpose they we talk
about things like trust and cooperation
in ways we didn't use to talk about them
before I could not have had a career in
the 80s and 90s no demand at all but now
I get to stand on stages and call Jack
Welch a bastard and people applaud the
movement is going in the right direction
so I'm optimistic
it took us 30 to 40 years to get where
we are today it's gonna take us 30 to 40
years to get to somewhere more
optimistic but this is why you're here
everybody here hasn't has raised their
hand and said count me in cuz it's not
it's not one of us that's all of us we
have to change the way we show up as
leaders we have to change the way we
build our companies we have to change
the way we show up as employees I don't
care if you work for a company with
10,000 people if you work with somebody
to the left and you work with somebody
to the right you can be a leader
leadership is the responsibility for
those around us to see those around us
rise and I think we're in good shape
we're moving in the right direction
thank you for being a part of it
[Applause]
hi thank you for hours amazing a quick
question on your third point which is
about the adversaries were worthy
adversaries worthy rival yeah and
picking your rival so in a more specific
way if you're a challenger brand for
example uh-huh
do you pick another challenger brand who
you consider worthy or is it about the
big incumbent that is not necessarily
worthy but a bigger rival so very often
with challenger brands there is some
sort of ideology that got them all angry
in the first place right before fired up
and even though you're not competing
against whatever the incumbency is of
the model they their mere existence
keeps you honest about what your cause
is so one of the best things that ever
happened to the West was the Soviet
Union because it reminded us what we
stood for because they existed and when
they went away things have kind of got a
little squirrelly because we have to
like remember without anybody to balance
it off right
Apple was really great when there was a
big thing and even people are
questioning what does Apple stand for
anymore it's hard to discern now right
so if you're a challenger brand the most
important thing is that we are standing
up against is the ideology not the
company because if you eventually get
big
you haven't won you haven't won they
just dropped out to suit America didn't
win the West didn't win the Cold War the
Soviet Union dropped out because they
ran under the will and resources to stay
in the game the Cold War is alive and
well I can give you a whole thing about
that if you want Cold War 2.0 I got a
whole theory and so if you're a
challenger brand then you you have to
know what you stand for and sometimes
the easiest way to know what you stand
for is to have something that is
different than what you stand for as
you're worthy rival but you have to keep
a strong ego because the goal is not to
beat them the goal is to spread your
gospel and not theirs
it's a rival gospel
yes hi Simon is Kirstie here I caught
one of your Instagram rambles in October
and I think he must have been finishing
this book in you were questioning
everything that you were doing
I caught it really early in the morning
here in Bodrum actually and you talked
about the why you were talking about
vision and mission
now that you've stated the five areas
there you have brought to life as a
group of leaders managers people who are
noting there is a movement happening
with how we work and how we show up what
would be one one area was a simple thing
that we could take away from tonight
that we could all start to do so the
those things that I told you about you
know you cannot do existential
flexibility without a just cause and I
would argue even trusting teams because
otherwise everybody's gonna panic and
think you're crazy
worthy rivalry like Just Cause and
trusting teams really are bigger than
the others existential flexibility is a
capacity you know so I think if if
there's one thing you can do it's it's
really it's articulating what that's all
for which begs the next question what's
the difference between Just Cause and
why right because I said start with why
now I'm saying start with Just Cause
are they the same did you change the
words in it
no the Y comes from the past the Y comes
in the past it's who you are
it's why the organization was founded
it's it's who you are as a human being
it's it's it's it's the thing that
drives you it is immutable it'll never
change no matter what happens in your
life
it comes from looking backwards a Just
Cause comes from looking forwards it is
an unrealized future that if your y2
were to be brought to life in the most
magical of ways the world that would
exist would be this world it is it is
the dream it is the fantasy we call it
vision because we can see it so you have
to be able to articulate what this world
looks like in terms so clearer than
other people go I can see it that sounds
amazing
sign me up so so challenge yourself and
then there's multiple ways to do it
if everything we did went perfectly what
would the world look like what will we
commit our organization to help build or
your life for without however you want
to look at it and then and then the path
to building trusting teams is the path
of good leadership that's what it is
so commit yourself to being the leader
you wish you had yes hi no you work here
okay you you you you can ask the
question - hi Simon
Yousef nice to meet you sir firstly
thank you for opening my mind and
thoughts in changing me interest rate of
leadership and a student of the infinite
game thank you thank you
keep - keep going thank you
second infinitely infinitely yes a
question to yet
- hopefully simple ones how can an
infinite a student of infinite theory
work influence or transform a finite
organization and - I'm really interested
in understanding the military concept
and I've listened to you a number of
times describe that and I've seen it in
programs in shows the military how can
it how it shapes minds to a point where
that individual will put the most
precious thing their life on the line
for the partner how can we create that
in our organizations no in the timeframe
of years but in the timeframe of weeks
and months like military yeah so let's
answer those questions in Reverse so one
of the things that I I have deep
admiration for the military and the
admiration I have for the military is
the exact same love and admiration I
have for artists is because they both
undertook their their their paths
knowing that they weren't going to get
rich and felt like it was a calling and
we're willing to sacrifice to advance
this thing whatever it is and be a part
of something so to me it the same it's
the same love and the thing that I
noticed immediately when I started
hanging out with folks in uniform is you
and I have colleagues and co-workers
they have brothers and sisters
they literally refer to the people they
work with as brothers and sisters and
the relationship is one of brother and
sister which is they may fight but they
you you try and attack my brother or
sister you got to go through me
they love each other love is the word
they we use that the Marine Corps calls
them the intangibles right that what
makes the Marine Corps strong are the
intangibles what they mean is empathy
love devotion these these these mushy
words and you're asking me a question
like how do we do it in weeks and months
it's it's it's a these are human beings
we're talking about right so that's like
asking me can I give you advice so that
you can fall in love in a matter of
weeks instead of having to do this whole
like
being vulnerable
I got no app for that it's a slow bloody
process sometimes you get lucky and you
have a meeting of the minds and you have
shared values and it goes a little
quicker but even though we get really
excited we jump in the relationship
three months where they were like what
was I thinking right there is no way to
speed up it takes more than a week but
if you've been doing something for seven
years and you don't love it maybe it's
wrong right I just don't know where it
happens so what I do know is that the
way you build trust inside an
organization is the exact same way you
fall in love right which is you devote
yourself to the care of another human
being sometimes at the sacrifice of your
own interests it means when the person
you love comes home from work and they
said I had a terrible day and you had an
amazing day you don't say a word about
your amazing day at all and you sit
there and listen with love and empathy
to their horrible day as opposed to
waiting for your turn to speak you know
it means that you wake up in the morning
you say good morning to them before you
check your phone it's the little things
it means you learn to listen and make
them and listening is really easy means
you you make the other person feel heard
so if you can go learn all of those
things on how to make a friend and how
to fall in love
now go do all of those things at work
then when somebody walks into office
goes oh [ __ ] my day
you go what's happening and you listen
so they feel heard don't get them advice
don't fix anything just listen right
when they tell you how awful it is say
that sucks
tell me more right it's the same thing
it's the exact same thing and I promise
you I promise you you will build those
relationships well you will fall in love
with the people you work with and you
will call them brothers and you will
call them sisters and they were the same
they will say the same of you so it's
that's how you do that and by the way
the military doesn't do it in 13 weeks
what they do is they create a foundation
for it in 13 weeks but it takes time for
those relationships to truly form and
the first question was how do we how
does it open mindset play in a finite
game and in a company that's driven by
finite by finite leaders that one's the
hardest one of all right because we
cannot change the mindset of people two
three four levels above us like there's
nothing we can do but if we adopt the
infinite mindset it's like preparing
yourself right it's like getting ready
for the eventual change that where
everybody else is it's like when the
internet showed up it's like most
companies panicked but there was a small
group of like oh we saw this coming a
long time ago right
Netflix one my favorite examples right
so Netflix you remember we used to
they made used to mail us the DVDs and
that's just because streaming technology
wasn't good enough yet but they knew was
coming of course it was going to improve
so they had this subscription model
blockbuster which was the number one
video rental place in the world
their CEO went to the board and said you
know we we should probably do this
subscription thing and the board said no
because they made 12 percent of their
revenues from late fees and look what
happened they're bankrupt and as soon as
the streaming got better Netflix was
there so what I would urge you to do is
maintain your infinite mindset but hone
it yet good at it practice leadership
don't worry about changing people's
minds you can't change be the leader for
the people around you and you may leave
the company because you choose to
because they want you out because
there's too many people who love you
I've seen that happen by the way I've
seen wonderful leaders get pushed out
because they have too much loyalty and
too much love towards them and the
senior leaders threatened I've seen it
happen right but be that person because
it's gonna change you here it's changing
I used to do these things I used to get
30 people show up we just filled central
hall right like this is the movement so
just keep at it because the revolution
is coming
go on this side yeah but you don't work
here you're just polite and well he was
there before me and you have to forgive
me if I static so I just realized how
many people are here and I am running
and own a theater school for kids and
for the last couple of years with our
old my older kids they've been going
through a lot it's all with exams
exception things like that so I've been
subliminally professing your ideals and
similar ones with like Bob Chatham and
Jim synagogue etc Branson and they found
it very very helpful but when I try and
talk to them about what their teachers
and their head teachers that their
schools are doing for them it seems very
much that schools those that haven't
already seem to be going the direction
of adopting the finite mind set of
results impact yep and I spoke to one of
their head teachers and said oh well
they were very quick to say look how
many of our students got 6 a start see
grades and I said to him well how many
more students were happy well they were
studying yeah cuz there's no point
having results if the kids are dead by
the end of the week and he looked me
like I was crazy
yeah and so I just thought if you had
any thoughts on this stuff in the
education system and any advice for yeah
apparent nutcases like me who are trying
to run you don't I just been told we're
idealists as if it's a bad thing yeah
yeah yep so you know one of the problems
in schools is that we run our schools
much like we run businesses which is
we've become more obsessed with the
metric than we have with the education
with the child you know we we don't
teach curriculum we teach children you
know and the education doesn't end when
they when they leave school and the
problem is is that teachers don't feel
taken care of the the leadership in
school is it's a corporate leadership
model and it's not where the the
Headmaster's have not obsessed with the
care of the teachers because if you get
that right the teachers will take care
of the students don't worry about it I
say it all the time
you know CEOs are not responsible for
the results so why you keep talking
about how you were responsible for the
customers the results you're not you're
responsible for the people who
responsible for the people who
responsible for the results there's not
a headmaster on the planet responsible
for the children
or the or the curriculum they're
responsible for the people who
responsible for the curriculum and the
children and if you get that hierarchy
right it works just fine so if you have
more forward-thinking parent you're
gonna go find a school that does that if
you if there's if you don't have a
choice and you're in a school that has
an old model then the way you will raise
your children and the way the kind of
pressures you will put on your children
will be slightly different there's
nothing wrong with teaching our kids
that they have to still do well at
school you know reality still exists I'm
not against reality I'm just an idealist
operating within it but but I think I
definitely think that we need school
reform and I think we need to teach the
fundamentals of leadership to anybody
who aspires to be a headmaster it gets
promoted to that position big change is
a charity that's doing is doing it
thanks for a great talk my name's drew
in over the industry I kind of lead a
project I'd like to call it a project
over business where we lead thousands of
people who have aligned to have values
who see the vision there's a serious
energy and great but like any growing
business or project it gets hungry and
and needs investment whether it's from
the banks or whether it's from the share
our investors my vision is infinite and
I align to what you say like Malcolm X
you are you're the next Malcolm X kind
of theory but on the other side the
shareholders when's my exit plan when's
this when's that they have a finite game
and because they hold the money strings
they think they can control the show
trying to play a finite game against my
infinite game how do you handle it
because every time they ask me the exit
what's your exit plan I kind of say well
it'd be the coffin and heart attack
probably but they don't take that
seriously what how do you handle that
infinite versus infinite finite players
in this same project trying to control
the strings did you get a say in you do
you own the company yes you took their
money yes
I got no problem I got no problem with
you looking for investors but you took
the number more than the investor you
you took the one who offered you more
money than you did from the person who
aligned to your values
you took the person who is investing in
the exit rather than is investing in you
and your vision yeah
Berkshire Hathaway does not sell the
stocks it buys find money from someone
who believes in you and your vision and
will give you the might of the of their
wealth of experience and the people who
work there to advise you rather than
force you into the exit make sense
Thanks
[Applause]
I feel I feel like I need to apologize
after that answer hi Simon hey thanks
for the talk and thanks say my question
as well and the first four pencils that
you spoke about it seems like it's
really under penned by cottage which you
spoke a lot about yeah and college - a
lot of people individually within teams
business is a scary thing yeah what
would you see Foster's cottage is that
an internal thing as a neat or is that
something that you actually seek from
from the people around you yeah so in my
experience courage is an external thing
I've had the opportunity to meet people
who have risked their lives to save the
lives of others and they didn't have to
they weren't they would not have been
faulted if they didn't they were not
ordered to they may have violated orders
in fact to do so and I've had the chance
to ask them why did you do it and almost
unanimously they say because they would
have done it for me and it's this sense
that someone has my back that gives me
the courage to do something for them you
know if you're a world famous tightrope
walker and you wanted to try a brand new
death-defying act for the first time
you're gonna do it with a net it's not
your ability that gave you the courage
even though you're really good at it
it's the net it's this external thing
that gave you the courage and you build
it so so I think that the the to live us
to live with a servant's heart to be
that that leader that empathetic leader
what that engenders is that people start
to believe that you have their backs
that you would do something for them
that you would sacrifice your interests
to to protect them and miraculously
they'll do it back and the only thing
that makes you a leader is you're the
one who went first you're the one who
took the risk first right that's the
only thing that makes you the leader
leaders not because you have the rank we
call you leader cuz you literally will
lead you led us you went first towards
the danger to take the risk you set the
tone
and people may have been cynical at the
start and you did it again and they may
have been cynical again and you did it
again and they realized wait this is for
real
and weird human things happen and they
start to offer you the same kind of love
and trust back
I believe it's external and I believe
it's based on the quality of human
relationships which means it doesn't
happen overnight like in the military
they do not build the trust in combat
it's not when they step off the plane
with their rifles and ions do they all
trust each other it's in peacetime where
their training and training and training
and training and learning to love each
other
the Israelis one of the most successful
militaries in military history the unit
that you train with when you're 18 years
old is your unit for the rest of your
life so when you're in your mid 40s and
you get called back for reserve it's the
same people you trained with when you
were 18 years old because they're so
understand that the bonds that you form
when you're a kid that they want those
bonds throughout your entire military
career they understand where the trust
comes from so I believe that that that
we talk about human beings we forget
we're social animals you know there's an
entire section in the book shop called
Self Help there is no section in the
book shop called help others and yet at
the end of the day by ourselves
we're crap like we're just not that good
by ourselves we're not that strong we're
not that clever but you give a team
together we can lift anything and solve
any problem not a single person on earth
solved any problem by themselves it
never happened and even if it was their
big brain there was somebody who
believed in them who gave them a break
or it funded them whatever it was they
did not do it alone and I think it's our
ability to foster relationships that
underpins the courage we need to do all
those difficult things hi hi Simon
yeah my name is Mark
so it's a two-part kind of question the
first one is when you go into
organizations and you talk to leaders
and tell them about bringing meaning and
purpose for the employees and they tell
you oh yeah we've got a well-being day
yeah organized once a year we've got
that covered
yeah like what would you have to tell
them the second thing is as the leader
yourself I guess of the organization
where do you fail as a leader where do
you recognize that you fail as a leader
let's ignore the second part of the
question and talk about the first one oh
by the way it's half past eight I
technically it's a 75 minute thing so if
you need to leave want to leave now is
the good time you want to fend me but
I'll keep going if you want to stay
[Applause]
okay so the first thing when people when
people say to me well we have a wellness
thing we got that covered my response is
about consistency versus intensity right
so if you if you stop brushing your
teeth and only go to the dentist twice a
year will your teeth fall out yes they
will right you cannot go to the gym for
nine hours and get into shape but if you
work at every single day for twenty
minutes
you absolutely get into shape I just
don't know when and the reason companies
like intensity is because it's easy to
measure we had the event we hired the
speakers we gave them or certificate
check they're all leaders right but it's
the daily little things it's the not
tons and tons of just innocuous things
that is what builds up they like
brushing your teeth
what does brushing your teeth for two
minutes do it does nothing unless you do
it every single day twice a day and it's
consistency that we forget about yes you
need intensity you still got to go to
the dentist but it's this balance of
intensity and consistency and too many
companies think they can solve a problem
with intensity and and I challenge them
to consider the consistency stuff so I
use the gym analogies and the brushing
of teeth analogies and and they get the
point where do I fail as a leader do we
we don't have enough time like any
person I can I can succumb to fatigue
and then all the things I talk about
sometimes I forget for me especially
when I'm writing a book I'm my worst
because I'm like teams I'm like working
with people I work better when I work
with people and writing a book is a very
lonely process and I actually get lonely
so all these negative thoughts Russian
that you then come out and I'm very
lucky that I have a couple of team
members who either tell me but more
importantly they they put up a little
barrier so that that it like I won't
hurt myself or hurt others
I I'm sometimes too too quick with
decisions like I'm very proud that I can
make big decisions but sometimes it's
too quick sometimes I need to listen for
just a minute more you know to find out
what something is I'm it's a work in
progress
it's a work in progress I'm constantly
learning on my listening ability it's
really funny I took this listening
course and this is what I learned I
learned that I am a tackle early good
listener with people who I will never
see again for the rest of my life
but the people who I love who are in my
life
terrible so when people say you're a bad
list and I'm like I write the book of
terrible terrible so I had to learn to
take the skills that I know but actually
apply them to people that I love so I'm
getting better I'm getting a lot better
you're welcome I just wanna finish I
think we're speaking on the same stage
in Greece and I also love Adam grant I
didn't know I was speaking of stage in
Greece but awesome who's next
yes we're go on the top back there Simon
thank you thank you very much for the
inspiring talk thank you and you framed
in a very Western way philosophies that
or you know waste of life lifestyles or
actions that for me ring true in a in an
Asian context whether it's yoga in
southern mhm southeastern Asia or the
the Chinese mentality of a million yo in
a liar how do you feel about the current
environment worldly and you mean how in
the West we're trying to win the China
as a thousand your plan is the
competition between the US and China on
Asia Asia is way ahead of us Asia's
playing an infinite game the Chinese are
playing into a game of course they're
playing if in a game they're just
waiting us out they make plans for
literally hundreds of years we make
plans for the next election cycle yeah I
think a lot of the stuff I talked about
is heavily Eastern
and the idea of infinite Ness an
infinite life it's heavily Eastern for
sure you know I think we have this funny
thing in the West where we like things
we can easily understand and we we don't
like to use things we don't understand
you know well I you know do you you know
love is a tricky thing to understand but
I know it exists I don't have a metric
for it I can't measure it but I know
it's there I love my children I love my
spouse you know show me the metric the
kids a you know pretty crap at school
and kind of a bit of a pain in the ass
and he beats up his sister and you still
love him I do it's hard to say it's hard
to put into metrics it's hard to put
into rational things and I think Eastern
philosophies embrace things we don't
understand better than we do and it's
about striking that right balance I
think we do the same thing with medicine
right like we cut the body up in two
systems and you're an expert and
whatever your system is and you know you
go see an endocrinologist it's clearly
glandular you know I like Eastern
philosophies as well they're like you
stick a needle in here and it helps your
knee well why you know it just does yeah
I think that's I think this is a
definitely a blending for sure and China
is ahead hi thanks for your wonderful
speech I had a question on the I guess
the general question about achieving
happiness on a day to day basis
given the infinite game idea if you're
at a workplace and like someone said
before you have an infinite mindset
we're in a finite structure on a day to
day basis you might get a bit
demoralized when you have to work when
you actually have a vision to do
something else but you want to do like
tedious tasks that you're not interested
in
I personally I'm just a student I'm a 20
year old student and I'm doing
engineering and I came in to study I
guess
as with the idea that I want to build
products that you know have an impact on
people that change people's perspective
of things and apps to help people well
our day to day basis a month of my
the university which is getting exams
done getting results done so how do I
don't how do I stop myself for getting
demoralizing a day-to-day basis while
this change for the you know future so I
make this distinction between joy and
happiness happiness comes when you win
the game when you get an A in your exam
happiness comes when your number comes
up in the lottery and then it goes away
you know that feeling joy is something
more underlying and you the u.s. how do
I have happiness on a day to day basis
you don't the things that you will do
you will not necessarily enjoy but the
question is do you have a sense that
they're a part of something bigger
that's where the that's where the the
value and the joy comes from you don't
have to like every day but you do get to
love every day you don't like your
children every day but you love your
children every day right and I think we
have this we've created this unrealistic
expectation that every day at work has
to be amazing like every day of your
relationship has to be amazing and every
day and your friendship has to be
amazing it's it's just not it's an
unfair standard to put on a human being
that's an unfair standard to put on an
organization and sometimes it's us
sometimes the organization is trying so
hard but we have a narrative in our head
that we can't let go of that it's us
that's creating the unhappiness every
day we make ourselves victims and
everything you see you'll find there all
the evidence well we can choose to
change our narrative you know I have a
friend who moved to from a liberal City
to a very conservative state city in the
United States and she was very worried
and I said to her it's the most
wonderful opportunity in the world she
says but I'm gonna hate all these people
I said or you can learn to listen
understand what their motivations are
and understand what what they care about
and I bet you'll discover that your
values are the same as theirs right some
of its narrative some of its perspective
don't seek happiness the happiness will
happen here and there it seek joy and
that comes from relationships and
belonging and cause
oh I have to stop I'll do one more one
more
hi hi first of all so I I'm kind of
exercising my courage here to you sir
sorry
exercising my courage to come and talk
to you thank you so first question is I
am a serial entrepreneur in the
technology and games industry and I also
have been building a YouTube channel
with a cause to encourage more young
girls to become entrepreneurs okay and
to also start their own companies cool
in the games and technology industry so
I would love to ask you if you would be
fine for me to interview you at some
point that's the first question I had to
ask sorry I love it do it good so second
question is about scaling so right now
my company has 70 people everyone based
in London and we have been doing pretty
well coming from you know zero to ten
but obviously as we scale the the
leadership team and everyone in the
organization needs to be multipliers of
everything than myself and my
co-founders have been you know in
stealing the organization so are there
some some ways for us to make sure that
we have multipliers in scale mm-hmm so
fundamentally scale breaks things you
know that right so organizations can be
like a family and then they had about 25
people and it starts to get really
complicated and a lot of organizations
struggle to get past that number because
now you need structure and hierarchy and
things that just make normal businesses
work right plus you're not all friends
anymore you didn't all grow up together
the first group of employees like we
were we actually were friends right so
you're up to 70 you said you know you
can still all know everybody's name you
still can refer to people you when
you'll max out about 150 then it gets
really complicated and scale just breaks
things for human beings we're just not
made for it
right so the way you do it is with
effective hierarchy you you should have
an effective training program to teach
leaders and should be considering
somebody's leadership abilities not just
there are results when you're promoting
people
and there should be an opportunity to
learn leadership practice leadership you
should be teaching it because you have
to create the environment in which you
have people who can keep the
organization organization going without
you
we call it the the School Bus theory
which is what happens to your company if
tomorrow you get hit by school bus
well it's fold will keep going right
hopefully keep going okay hopefully
would keep going hopefully so we're
relying on hope hope is not a good
business plan right
how about it'll absolutely keep going
cuz the cause is crystal clear and
everybody we hired believed in the cause
and even if they were the best qualified
person because we suspect that they
didn't share our values I believe no
course we didn't hire them right there
was somebody who's toxic in the
organization and we coach them coaching
them coach and they proved to be
uncoachable and even though they were
the highest performing organization in
the world that sales person sells more
than anybody else
we made the difficult decision to ask
them to leave to go and find joy hat
somewhere else they're a good person
they're just bad fit right but those are
hard decisions and those are the kinds
of decisions that other people see you
making that you actually do believe in
your cause more than your growth
planning because the problem with growth
plans is they're arbitrary you made it
up how big you want to be in two years
five years ten years is literally a work
of fiction right and then we got all
bogged down if it works or Danka we're
not going on pace now yes that stuff's
important good to have goals it's good
to have things to reach for yes but
they're there they're there to push us
but they're not they're not there to
determine that where we've succeeded or
we failed right it's something to give
us the strifer because we're still
visually driven annuals we're still like
dopamine to drive us we still like
short-term things to help us it's not a
the infinite game it still includes
finite games yeah so I think - in order
for you to scale you have to ensure that
the people who you're putting in
leadership positions aren't just good at
their jobs they're good leaders there's
plenty of data on this that top sales
people don't necessarily may
great sales managers there's there's no
correlation great sales managers are
good at getting the sales people to be
at their natural best and they're okay
not making any sales themselves there's
no correlation so you are you promoting
your top performers you're promoting
your best leaders and you better be
teaching them how to lead once you
promote them thanks very much everybody
[Applause]
[Music]